le président giscard d'estaing à juan
carlos oui à l'espagne dans le rough
mais des problèmes restent à régler le
temps juillet-août novembre mal de la
grisaille le temps des vacances des
réactions après le cartes sur table
d'hier le bureau politique du bc attaque
jamais de torres vermeer madame et
monsieur juno enfin min devant dieu
partent en voyage de noces
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir ça
y est ils sont partis ils étaient 110
cet après midi juché chacun sur une
bicyclette pour entamer la grande boucle
et devinez qui demain matin portera le
maillot jaune est bien ce sera le
vainqueur de l'an passé vous le voyez
sur votre écran bernard thévenet car
bernard thévenet aujourd'hui n'a pas
remporté l'étape contre la montre qui
était disputée sur 5 km 200 en hollande
il ne l'a pas remporter car cette étape
s'est avérée finalement initie le temps
était trop mauvais les organisateurs ont
décidé que cette étape ne jouerait pas
pour l'attribution du maillot de leader
les coureurs sont donc partis pour
l'honneur essai pour l'honneur que
quatre hollandais ont pris les quatre
premières places
hollande c'est normal le prologue étant
finalement remporté par race mauvais
temps hollande mauvais en belgique en
angleterre dans une partie de
l'allemagne mauvais temps enfin chez
nous tout au moins sur la moitié nord de
la france
un ciel qui désespère les vacanciers ce
2 juin revienne furieux ceux du mois de
juillet s'interroge quant aux routes
pour les départs elle risque d'être bien
humide alors laurent broomhead que nous
promettait vous pour le week end mais à
écouter le mauvais temps continue avec
tout de même une légère amélioration
pour vous l'expliqué bien j'ai avec moi
un invité il s'appelle météo ça c'est un
satellite de l'agencé spatiale
européenne
il est en orbite juste au dessus du
golfe de guinée d'où ils photographient
la terre toutes les 30 minutes sur cette
maquette au 20e
vous voyez les panneaux solaires qui
alimentent les instruments parmi
lesquels les appareils photographiques
qui vise la planète à travers cette
fenêtre avec ses antennes et bien ils
transmettent les informations au sol à
darmstadt en allemagne où ils sont
répercutés sur l'ensemble du pays et
pour l'une des premières fois vous allez
voir une photographie meteosat prise
hier sur cette photographie nous avons
certes et la france d'un petit trait
noir vous voyez qu'au sud et bien le
temps est finalement assez clair assez
dégagé tandis qu'au nord circulent
d'ouest en est une série de zones de
mauvais temps voilà qui explique le
mauvais temps que nous avons connues
dernièrement cela je vous ai dit va
s'améliorer parce que les nuages petit
si on remonte vers le nord d'ailleurs si
vous avez chez vous un baromètre un
thermomètre vous verrez leurs
indications remonte petit à petit alors
demain
vendredi ce grand jour de départ en
vacances eh bien la france fait divisée
en deux par une grande bande de mauvais
temps du beau redonner à la charente
jusqu'au hall à la lorraine et au nord
des alpes
avec donc des nuages et des averses au
sud un assez beau temps et du soleil un
peu de nuance tout de même et au nord
des passages nuageux mais avec des
belges et leurs sites ou de maine dans
l'après-midi et bien il y aura des
orages de l'aquitaine à la lorraine sous
le nom de la france près de paris
et pour les grands départs en vacances
et bien il y aura des éclaircies de plus
en plus belle sauf sur la manche où il y
aura encore quelques averses et le temps
samedi et bien samedi il y aura de la
brume ce soit le matin alors attention à
ce qu'on choisit ce moment là pour
partir en vacances ce le reste du pays
bien il y aura encore des nuages midi
cite l'article que je pense finale
finiront par dominer à noter quelques
orages sur les pyrénées sur les alpes
sur la méditerranée les températures
vont s'élever petit à petit on peut dire
que pratiquement elles vont rejoindre
les normales saisonnières
malheureusement il ya malheureusement
sur l'ouest dans l'après-midi reviendra
une zone de mauvais temps il y aura à
nouveau des pluies sur la côte
en conclusion le temps s'améliore petit
à petit le mois de juillet ne serait
peut-être pas aussi mauvais tout san
mais on ne peut pas affirmer on ne peut
pas l'affirmer la semaine prochaine il y
aura sans doute à nouveau des passages
nuageux sur le nord de la france merci
laurent rien de très très bons donc pour
tous ceux qui demain et après vont
prendre la route pour se rendre qui en
bretagne qui dans le centre qui sur la
côte méditerranéenne ou sur la côte
atlantique
car il n'y aura pas que le temps il y
aura aussi les bouchons et les
embouteillages et la technique a fait de
très gros progrès maintenant on peut
savoir avant de partir où et combien de
temps on restera bloquée ne partez pas
le samedi 1er juillet de préférence
choisissez le vendredi ou le dimanche
mieux encore porter le lundi
si vous partez vendredi éviter de
prendre la route entre 15h et 21h
si malgré tout vous partez le samedi
bison futé déconseille de le faire entre
3 heures et 15 heures dimanche c'est
entre six heures et midi que les routes
seront le plus chargé attendait dans
l'après midi
et sur ces graphiques qui lie à un
bouchon qui n'est pas indiqué celui-là
n'était pas prévisible par les
ordinateurs puisqu'il dépend uniquement
du bon vouloir des douaniers italiens
ceux ci sont en grève depuis le début de
la semaine résultat rien qu'au tunnel du
mont-blanc 800 camions sont bloqués il
forme un bouchon de près de 6 km de long
et la grève des douaniers italiens
pourrait se poursuivre encore plusieurs
choix tout cela explique peut-être la
morosité qui existent en france à la
veille de ses vacances d'été morosité
d'un certain nombre de nos compatriotes
une morosité qui se traduit parfois par
un accablement parfois par un énervement
nous sommes interrogés sur les raisons
profondes de ce mal qui nous atteint
touche à une époque où généralement la
décontraction est plutôt de rigueur et
la réponse ou plutôt l'une des réponses
possibles
nous l'avons trouvé chez un psychologue
le départ en vacances pour beaucoup de
gens c'est synonyme de la possibilité
d'un temps plus libre
le beau temps permet justement d'être
dans la nature d'être au soleil devient
alors dès que le mauvais temps menace on
en parle d'ailleurs d'une menace de
mauvais temps pour beaucoup de gens
c'est vraiment leur détente qui est
menacée on comprend qu'ils puissent est
morose comment ça se traduit exactement
dans les faits d'abord ça se traduit par
le fait que tout le monde en parle et se
plaint du mauvais temps vous savez à
quel point le temps est un très bon
sujet de rencontre je crois que c'est
parce que vraiment ça touche les gens
assez profondément haut niveau leur vie
affective
nous sommes des gens anxieux en fin de
compte et le mauvais temps est synonyme
de d'anxiété de peine de découragement
de dépression c'est pour ça je crois que
pour beaucoup de gens la crainte du
mauvais temps des robes roses les
vacances ce n'est pas seulement
d'attraper le plus fort coup de soleil
qu'on pourra montrer à ses amis c'est la
possibilité de prendre son temps c'est
peut-être pas le boni le mauvais temps
mais simplement déjà prendre son temps
savoir goûter un peu de temps un peu de
lenteur et il y a des tas de richesses
en nous-mêmes qui ne peuvent se
développer que si on prend le temps de
l'écouter ce qui à l'intérieur soi même
et à l'intérieur des autres dans des
communications qui sont peut-être plus
détendu et plus profonde parce que on va
peut-être rester à certains moments
entre deux averses à l'intérieur a
discuté tranquillement autour d'un bon
peut pourquoi pas enfin toujours à
propos des congés d'été le gouvernement
entend lui aussi remonté le moral des
français
faire connaître la france aussi bien aux
français qu'aux étrangers développer le
tourisme rural et surtout faciliter
l'accès de plus de français encore aux
vacances tels sont les objectifs du
ministre de la jeunesse des sports et
des loisirs monsieur jean pierre soisson
mais parmi les projets de monsieur
soissons on trouve également la création
d'un titre vacant ce qui serait en
partie payées par l'employeur qui a très
nombreux français de classes modestes
des ouvriers qui ne partent pas en
vacances et je voudrais aussi me
préoccupait de la situation de ceux là
et le faire en sorte qu'ils puissent
demain partir l'accord et pour ce faire
avec le patronat avec les syndicats
ouvriers nous allons mettre à l'étude
des formules de titres vacances et c'est
à dire un peu la formule du ticket
restaurant que certains utilisent à
l'heure du déjeuner étendu à l'ensemble
des activités d'hôtellerie et de
restauration
c'est un projet je souhaite qu'il puisse
être mené à bien
mais c'est pas le gouvernement seul qui
mettra cette affaire en application
c'est le gouvernement en liaison avec
avec les partenaires sociaux
jean pierre soisson vous le dites
vous-même ils partiront tous ou presque
tous demain leur grande préoccupation
finalement c'est le temps il va
commencer à pleuvoir là vous ne pouvez
rien faire en tant que ministre des
loisirs j'ai encore jamais été
ambassadeur auprès de dieu sait ce que
vous me demandez alors le temps c'est
une donnée
naturel je souhaite qu'il fasse beau et
je n'y peux rien nous le souhaitons tous
voilà pour ce chapitre
l'entrée de l'espagne dans la communauté
européenne est conforme à l'intérêt de
tous l'espagne attendait cette phrase
hier soir elle n'a pas été déçue par
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
aujourd'hui le chef de l'état s'est
rendu à l'hôtel de ville de madrid
j'ai bien l'intention de revenir dans
votre ville at il déclaré en réponse au
discours de bienvenue du maire de la
capitale espagnole
nous trouvons sur place à madrid notre
envoyé spécial bernard benyamin depuis
quelques semaines depuis l'annoncé
officielle de son voyage en espagne
valéry giscard d'estaing a confirmé à
deux reprises en moins de 24 heures
c'est bien l'europe c'est bien la
volonté espagnole de s'intégrer à la
communauté européenne qui constitue le
plat de résistance de ce voyage en
espagne
nous souhaitons profondément l'entrée de
l'espagne dans le marché commun a dit
hier soir en substance valéry giscard
d'estaing au cours du dîner offert en
son honneur par le roi juan carlos et ça
pose des problèmes graves ce qui a posé
problème à la france à l'espagne et à la
communauté européenne c'est ce même
langage que régis car destin tient en ce
moment même au sénat devant les corps
constitués
mais si vous voulez bien commençons par
le commencement
il est 10 heures 40 ce matin lorsque
valéry giscard d'estaing se rend à
l'hôtel de ville de madrid
précédé d'un détachement de la garde
royale c'est l'occasion pour le
président de la république de parcourir
les rues de madrid pour aller en
recevoir les clés de la capitale
espagnole 45 minutes plus tard c'est
l'arrivée au sénat où valéry giscard
d'estaing va réaffirmer devant tous les
parlementaires les positions de la
france relative à l'entrée de l'espagne
dans le marché commun la france est
favorable à l'entrée de l'espagne dans
la communauté européenne
elle est convaincue que c'est son
intérêt comme c'est celui de l'espagne
et comme c'est celui de l'europe il est
évidente l'adhésion de l'espagne gérera
une situation nouvelle est que cela
exigera de chacun de nous je dis de
chacun de nous un vigoureuse efforts
d'adaptation
il en résultera certes des problèmes
pour la france dont certains secteurs
agricoles doivent pouvoir continuer à
exercer de façon satisfaisante leur
activité et assurer l'emploi de ceux qui
travaillent il en résultera aussi et ce
n'est pas à vous que je la prendrai des
problèmes pour l'espagne qui devront
s'ouvrir davantage à une concurrence
extérieure vigoureux
après ce que la presse espagnole
appellera peut-être demain matin le
discours de l'europe
le président de la république et madame
giscard d'estaing prennent la route du
palais de la zarzuela
la résidence des souverains espagnols à
quelques kilomètres de madrid va servir
de cadre
un déjeuner privé dans une ambiance très
détendue entre le roi la reine d'espagne
et leurs invités
l'après-midi ce sera en hélicoptère le
survol de ségovie et une visite au
palais de la gran faim demeure du xviiie
siècle fameuse pour ses jardins à la
française
hier soir au palais royal de madrid juan
carlos et dounia sophie a recevait le
couple présidentiel ce soir c'est le
président de la république qui offrent
aramco est ce une réception en l'honneur
des souverains espagnols
une nouvelle occasion d'être le témoin
de la courtoisie des rapports au sein du
monde politique en espagne il y avait
felipe gonzalez le secrétaire du parti
socialiste
santiago carillo le secrétaire général
du parti communiste
tous seront présents ce soir pour
répondre à l'invitation du président
français radio hanoi a officiellement
démenti ce matin l'entrée de ses troupes
en territoire cambodgien selon la radio
nord-vietnamienne la radio vietnamienne
plus tôt au cours des derniers jours ce
serait en fait plusieurs régiments de
soldats cambodgiens qui aurait violé les
frontières et n'amène dans commettant de
nombreux cris en italie à un peu plus
d'un millier de grands électeurs sont
réunis depuis 16h cet après midi ils ont
à élire le successeur de monsieur
giovanni léonais président
démissionnaire ils doivent élire en
effet le septième président de la
république italienne
les trois premiers tours de scrutin du
parlement ne compte pas puisqu'il faut
la majorité des 2/3 impossibles à réunir
par la suite la majorité absolue suffit
mais cela veut dire que la démocratie
chrétienne ne peut faire élire son
candidat sont lapointe des autres partis
un président de gauche ce sera très
difficile sans l'accord des démocrates
chrétiens alors 20 ans votée pendant
deux semaines comme il ya sept ans pour
l'élection de giovanni les hommes en
principe ce sera plus rapide une
question de jours tout de même jusqu'à
les démocrates chrétiens les communistes
font partie maintenant de la mer ne
serait t gouvernementale et puis en
cette période de crise et de scandales
peut-on s'offrir le luxe d'un marathon
humiliant
d'après un sondage 70% des italiens
demande un président qui soit avant tout
onex le problème c'est qu'il ne suffit
pas d'être honnête pour être élu
président de la république italienne
probablement dans quelque chose nouvel
attentat à jérusalem trois personnes ont
été tuées et 25 autres blessés par
l'explosion d'une bombe ce matin dans un
marché de la capitale israélienne la
charge de dynamite avait été déposé dans
des toilettes publiques
elle a causé des dégâts très importants
les auteurs de cet attentat n'ont pas
été retrouvés par la police
regrets indignation le parti communiste
français a jugé très sévèrement
aujourd'hui les propos tenus hier soir
sur notre antenne pendant cartes sur
table par da par madame jeannette
vermeersch la veuve de maurice thorez
pour laurent salini dans l'humanité les
propos de madame jeannette vermeersch
constitue une attaque frontale contre la
direction et du parti communiste
français attaques dont la droite
évidemment écrit laurent salini se
servira et puis aujourd'hui toujours le
bureau politique du parti communiste a
lui aussi vivement réagi le bureau
politique exprime son regret et son
indignation de l'attitude de jeu le site
la camarade jeannette tendresse
vermeersch il affirme sa conviction que
les communistes ne permettrons pas que
leur parti souhaite entraîner dans la
voie du morcellement en clans et et
groupes rivaux s'affrontent entre leurs
copains que l'on peut dire ce soir que
c'est une réaction qui n'est pas
extrêmement surprenante mais avec
lesquels vous savez que nous aurions
voulu ce soir donnait la parole un
communiste nous avions d'abord pensé à
un jeune il aurait pu dire en quoi il se
sentait proche ou très différent de
jeannette vermeersch qui représente une
autre génération
et puis nous avons pensé ensuite un
dirigeant du parti communiste après le
communiqué dont vous avez parlé nous
sommes heurtés à nous sommes heurtés à
un refus
le pc donc se dit indigné et pensent que
l'intervention de jeannette vermeersch
rentrer dans une grande campagne
anticommuniste
mais qu'est-ce qui a pu choquer ainsi le
parti communiste dans les propos de la
veuve de maurice tanguay je crois qu'il
ya d'abord le fait que cette
intervention en elle-même va relancer va
réactiver tous les remous autour du
débat interne du parti communiste et
puis un certain nombre de critiques
précise de jeannette vermeersch la
première pour elle il y à un partage des
responsabilités entre communistes et
socialistes dans l'échec électoral de la
gauche alors le parti communiste ne peut
pas tolérer qu'une de ses militantes yen
ce langage puisque pour lui seul le
parti socialiste poste porte la
responsabilité de l'échec
deuxième critique la direction du parti
communiste estime jeannette vermeersch a
passé le centralisme démocratique par
dessus bord le centralisme démocratique
vous savez c'est l'ensemble des règles
qui régissent la vie interne la vie
démocratique du parti il ya une critique
indirecte qui compte ce sont estimées
jeannette vermeersch les changements les
évolutions que par ailleurs elle
condamne ce sont ces changements à ces
évolutions qui ont engendré des esprits
comme celui de jordan times
qui dit elle cherche maintenant à tirer
le parti vers le marais social démocrate
mais je crois que par delà ces critiques
et par delà les propos il y à aussi il
ya peut-être surtout le personnage de
jeannette vermeersch avec ses cheveux
blancs ses yeux bleus sa voix cassée qui
lui donnent parfois détonante accents de
sincérité
la veuve de maurice thorez représente
toute une génération du parti communiste
et puis aussi avec ses certitudes avec
ses principes avec ces affirmations
parfois péremptoire qui hier soir n'ont
pas surpris non pas choqué que les
communistes
elle représente finalement toute une
partie est toute une période de
l'histoire du parti communiste elle
affirme qu'elle parle au nom de l'avenir
mais elle est le témoin présent
peut-être aussi le témoin gênant d'un
passé avec lequel le parti communiste
voudrait rompre elle est apparue un peu
si vous voulez comme l'image inverse de
l'image que le parti communiste a voulu
donner de lui-même lors de son 22ème
congrès du côté de la majorité le débat
pour être moins spectaculaires existe
aussi le rpr semble en effet craindre
l'échec de la politique économique menée
par le premier ministre on a
l'impression que le parti gaulliste veut
s'en démarquer au maximum avec comme
objectif pour monsieur jacques chirac
d'anticiper sur l'éventuelle grogne du
groupe parlementaire afin de démontrer
que les députés du rpr sont unanimes
dernière lui mais alors reste
l'éternelle question jusqu'où vert perd
ira-t-il dans ses critiques
à partir de quel seuil pourra-t-il
refusé sa confiance dans le gouvernement
la réponse de jacques chirac simplement
à partir du moment où nous passerions
d'une divergence sur les cheminements à
emprunter pour atteindre les objectifs
qui nous sont communs à une divergence
de vue sur ses objectifs
nous sommes une partie est une partie
importante de la majorité elle c'est à
ce titre que nous multiplions nos mises
en garde ou nos interventions pour
tenter de convaincre le gouvernement à
qui il appartient d'assumer la
responsabilité et de tirer les
conclusions qu'il souhaitera des avis
émis par sa majorité de le convaincre de
la nécessité de prendre des mesures de
cette nature je ne sais pas si nous y
arriverons
eh bien nous verrons bien si tôt la
conférence de presse du président du rpr
terminé les journalistes sont allés voir
comment
le parti républicain réagissait aux
propos de l'ancien premier ministre
malien le p r a réagi et même vivement
sans citer toutefois ni le nom de
monsieur chirac ni celui du mouvement
qu'il préside
pour monsieur jacques blanc les français
en tout cas n'ont rien à faire de la
volonté tactique de certains de se
placer pour être franc je vous dirais
que trop c'est trop et que il me paraît
dangereux de jeter le doute dans les
esprits
et quand on souffle au chaud et de froid
on jette le doute dans les esprits au
moment où au contraire nous souhaitons
quant à nous que tous les français
comprennent bien que notre seul objectif
c'est d'assurer un emploi stable sûr et
permanent à tous les français or il faut
bien savoir qu'il n'y a pas d'autre voie
pour atteindre un tel objectif que celle
du redressement économique qui dure et
qui suppose donc une action continue en
profondeur et d'efforts mais il faut
avoir le courage de dire aux français et
je crois que le moment n'est pas aux
états d'âme et les français se moquent
des états d'âme des leaders politiques
mais au contraire le moment est de
permettre que les vrais problèmes soient
traitées et d'une manière durable car je
me méfie des coups de fouet dont on a
parfois du mal à se remettre
monsieur jean-jacques servan-schreiber
n'est plus député de la meurthe et
moselle le conseil constitutionnel a
annulé les résultats du deuxième tour du
mois de mars dernier
monsieur jean-jacques servan-schreiber
de l'avait à l'époque emporté que de 22
voix sur son adversaire socialiste
monsieur ton dont 22 voix sur plus de
65000 suffrages exprimés première
réaction de jjss je serai à nouveau
candidat le viol sera désormais encore
plus sévèrement sanctionné
le sénat a adopté cette nuit à
l'unanimité une législation
particulièrement répressive cinq à dix
ans de réclusion criminelle pour les
coupables de violences sexuelles
cette proposition va maintenant être
soumis à nouveau à l'approbation de
l'assemblée nationale
ce texte aura été d'ailleurs le dernier
adopté par les sénateurs la session
parlementaire de printemps est en effet
terminée le président du sénat monsieur
alain poher s'est félicité dans son
discours de clôture du rôle renforcé
joué par la haute assemblée
il a souhaité que la réforme des
collectivités
local répondent aux voeux des maires à
l'assemblée monsieur jacques chaban
delmas a de son côté invité les députés
à réfléchir durant l'intercession haut à
des projets de loi de justice de
responsabilité nécessaire à une société
en pleine évolution
au palais du luxembourg comme mon palais
bourbon c'est monsieur raymond barre qui
a répondu à chacun des présidents
le premier ministre a réaffirmé que dans
la ligne des orientations définies par
le président de la république et fort de
la confiance accordée au gouvernement
par la majorité
il mènera son action dans la voie fixée
dans les circonstances difficiles où
nous sommes voie qui est celle de la
rigueur et de l'effort mais avant de se
séparer et de partir donc en vacances
les sénateurs ont mis à jour leur
dossier
c'est ainsi que le rapport de la
commission d' enquête sur le naufrage de
l'amoco cadiz a été rendue publique
premières conclusions de ce rapport on
ne pourra réellement chiffrées avant un
an ou deux peut-être les dommages
écologiques causés par le naufrage de ce
pétrolier premières conclusions de la
commission donc la responsabilité civile
de l'armateur est totalement engagé
vis-à-vis de toutes les victimes y
compris l'état français mais il n'y a
pas de lampistes précise la commission
ce qui est en cause c'est la
responsabilité d'un système je cite où
l'administration qu'elle est pouvoir n'a
pas les moyens celle qui a les moyens
n'a pas les pouvoirs
celle qui à l'information n'a ni les
moyens ni les pouvoirs 300 pages de
rapports sévères donc qui a été adoptée
à l'unanimité des membres de la
commission
quelle mesure préconisent les sénateurs
d'abord une série de démarches sur le
plan international la france n'est pas
seule en cause pour mieux réglementer le
trafic maritime
il faudra renforcer le contrôle des
états définir les responsabilités des
grandes compagnies de navigation sur nos
côtes même qu'il faudra que le préfet
maritime soit le véritable patron et
qu'il dispose d' équipes d'intervention
spécialisés surveillance radar
remorqueur recherche
il faudrait 5 milliards de francs pour
étendre un tel dispositif à l'ensemble
des côtes françaises
une tâche qui ne se fera pas en un jour
mais il est urgent que les premiers
crédits soient dégagés des 79 insiste la
commission le danger demeure et noir est
un danger permanent
aujourd'hui je produisais a même un
événement dans les mêmes circonstances
atmosphériques
les mêmes causes produiraient les mêmes
chefs c'est à dire que depuis 100 jours
nous n'avons pas avancé il faut donc
maintenant que le gouvernement prenne
ses responsabilités ceci dit il faut
aussi avoir l'honnêteté rappeler que
quelles que soient les dispositions
prises elles ne feront que limiter les
risques d'un drame mais ne pourront pas
à coup sûr les empêcher celui que la
france entière appelait le petit juge le
juge pascal a été condamné aujourd'hui à
2000 francs d'amendé avec sursis pour
violation du secret de l'instruction et
du secret professionnel
c'est le tribunal de grande instance de
rennes qui a rendu ce jugement dernier
volet de la sphère du meurtre de
brigitte devaivre à bruay-en-artois les
jeunes femmes musulmanes sont elles
mêmes en occident victimes des
traditions après la ferme à skis nos
sept jeunes algériennes de 26 ans enlevé
il y a deux mois à montréal par l'un de
ses frères mais content qu'elle était
poussée un français non musulmans
voici la faire naïma el et marocaines à
la 14 ans est elle aussi ses parents
voudraient l'obliger à respecter la
coutume
tout a débuté il ya quelques mois dans
une banlieue ouvrière de nantes le
quartier bellevue la 50% de français 50
% d'immigrés maghrébins tous d'un milieu
ouvrier travaillant dans le bâtiment où
les chantiers navals au milieu de la
cité 1 cs 1 6 e est fréquente et naïma
une enfant de 14 ans une petite
marocaine un trimestre m est une enfant
tout procès manque un problème tant
évolué c'est d'elle que pour moi même
qui était ponctuelle qui travaillent est
qui qui participaient en fait compte
correctement d'être injecté de la classe
à l'avant crise claires en janvier et
bien naïve mater toute différente
l arrivée chaque matin de plus en plus
triste
c'est facile explique évidemment quand
on voit le recul de 6 mois mais à
l'époque c'était vraiment une tristesse
l'affolant pour une enfant elle nous a
dit voilà ma mère veut marier il ya un
type qui vit chez moi et bon ben je
prenais passat tellement sérieusement
nous c'est un peu inquiété sur le coup
quoi
c'est après après les fiançailles que
neymar est venu nous demander son aide
et elle est arrivé une fois l'école à me
fait voir les traces de coups qu'elle
avait sur la tête elle avait des grosses
bosses enfin beaucoup de traces et on ne
m'a parlé à une prof fans qui vont elle
a tout de suite et ai été vraiment
indigne et enfin elle en a parlé à
cesser ses collègues et nous on a dit
bon ben on a écrit une lettre maintenant
à vous de le faire
c'est donc grâce aux copains d'école que
140 signatures sont réunis dans la cité
le corps enseignant alerte la justice
naïma et placé dans un foyer de jeunes
filles dans la mayenne les parents de
naïma partagé entre les traditions
musulmanes et la vie européenne sont le
reflet de milliers de maghrébins
installés sur le territoire français
mais évidemment naïma n'a que 14 ans et
elle est musulmane
pour son père et sa mère l'avenir de
naïma était déjà tracé
au début je voulais la mariée alors on
les fiancés et le mariage n'aurait eu
lieu qu'au bout de trois ou quatre ans
maintenant c'est fini je voudrais savoir
aussi quel âge s'est marié votre maman
et jacquard a marqué 12 mois je me suis
mariée à 14 ans mais je n'en pense rien
les images se mariera avec qui et quand
elle voudra on dit aussi donné imac
qu'elle aurait été battu bon il ya eu
des certificats médicaux qui ont prouvé
que l'enfant avait été battu dans madame
tâche
je n'ai pas frappé mais elle est
peut-être tombé ou peut-être elle s'est
battue est-ce que vos parents ont
l'intention maintenant de faire quelque
chose pour que naïma sortent du foyer
est il ce qu'il dit mon mimi s'il voit
le juge lui parle il comprend rien si
juste dit qu'il a l'intention d'aller
voir un avocat pour la sociaux naïma
naïma henneberry une affaire mais
surtout une question égale pour tous la
loi française n'a cherché qu'à protéger
l'enfant mais peut-elle être appliquée à
des étrangers aux coutumes et aux
traditions si différentes des nôtres
mes petits enfants suisses pourront
désormais même si leurs parents s'ils
refusent se faire raconter de belles
histoires un écrivain helvétique vient
d'avoir l'idée de créer un service de
contes pour enfants par téléphone
heureuse suisse la communication durera
4 minutes et les contes de fées seront
changés nous assure-t-on tous les mois
puisque nous sommes dans le rêve je vous
propose de continuer puisque en ce
moment même monsieur et madame juno sont
parait-il en pleine mer une lune de miel
enchanteresse mais rendue quasiment
obligatoire puisque le bateau qui les
abritent constitue l'un des innombrables
cadeaux de mariage qu'ils ont reçus
après 24 heures de réflexion la
princesse caroline de monaco et philippe
junod qui avait été unie hier selon la
loi monégasque ont confirmé aujourd'hui
en échangeant leurs anneaux qu'il
n'avait pas changé d'avis
et philippe vivait dans la joie en douce
et non comme vous l'avez pas à vrai dire
on s'y attendait un peu c'est pourquoi
au palais princier tout avait été prévu
pour la cérémonie religieuse une
cérémonie qui devait à l'origine se
dérouler dans la chapelle palatine
mais avec ses 14 mètres 60 sur 6 mètres
40 la chapelle se révéla un peu juste
pour accueillir la traîne de la mariée
les parents les témoins et la
soixantaine d'invités attendu ainsi la
cérémonie s'est elle déroulée dans la
cour même du palais et comme le soleil
s'était invité à la dernière minute le
doux visage de la princesse sans trop
bas encore plus radieux
voilà cette édition est maintenant
terminée à 22h50 c'est gérard holtz qui
vous présentera notre dernier journal
quant à moi j'espère vous retrouver
demain à 20h à ceux qui partent en tout
cas je souhaite bien sûr bonne route et
je leur dis surtout soyez prudents aux
autres bonne soirée et à demain